>> Hello. Good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen.
Wonderful to see you all here.
My name is Marie Arana, and
I am the literary director
of this festival.
Very happy to welcome you here.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much
for coming out.
Now, sitting next to
me, I want to announce,
is not Secretary
Madeleine Albright.
[laughter]
>> Amy Tan: I will be talking
about fascism, however.
>> And before we start, I
just want to take a moment
to say a very big thank you
to our sponsors and donors.
This festival would not happen
without the funding from people
like you, sponsors, donors.
Go down to the expo floor,
please tell them
thank you very much
for putting this festival on.
No amount is too small,
so if you're willing
to contribute, we
ask that you do.
It is, it takes a lot
of money to put this
on to give it to you for free.
So, thank you very much.
Yes. [applause] We want
to keep doing that.
We want to keep giving
it to you for free.
Now this is, I'm sitting next to
Amy Tan, who is the only author
at this festival, we've
got 115 authors here today,
who was chosen by PBS'
The Great American Read.
[ Applause ]
Chosen as a book by the
public, by the American public,
and there's going to be
voting on all of the 100 books
that were chosen, chosen
for having written a book,
it was the Joy Luck Club,
that changed their lives.
And yeah, wow.
>> Amy Tan: I didn't--
thank you whoever voted.
[ Applause ]
>> Joy Luck Club was followed of
course by A Kitchen God's Wife
and The Hundred Secret Senses
and The Bonesetter's Daughter,
all of her fiction, which
has been extraordinary,
and the nonfiction as well.
Saving Fish from Drowning,
The Valley of Amazement,
and now the wonderful
memoire that she's written,
that she's given to
us, and we're going
to be talking about today.
But I have to say, Amy, and I'll
start with this, I am Hispanic.
When I read your book, Joy Luck
Club, I felt a real connection
because you, it is
families who come
to this country bringing
their own culture,
bringing their own tradition,
coming here with a
completely different universe,
and suddenly you are
American, generations change,
distances grow, tell us about
you, how you feel about--
>> Amy Tan: I thought it, yeah,
I thought it was so ironic
because when I was
writing that book,
I thought no one is
going to get this book.
This is going to be so
weird because are going
to say nobody had
a family like that,
and a lot of the stories were
based at least emotionally
and situationally on my family,
and so I was so surprised
when Chinese American women
or men said this book was,
they identified with it.
But then, as you said, I
had people from all sorts
of backgrounds tell me that.
>> Well the interesting thing
to me is that reading it
and reading books like yours,
Maxine Hong Kingston's
Warrior Woman, these books,
you realize that there's another
way to think as a citizen
of this country, as a part
of this fantastic
American experience,
we all come with different
heads and different histories.
>> Amy Tan: I think that we
also come with a similar heart,
and that's where it comes
from, this connection,
and if you can get people
to feel what you're feeling
in the story, you have more
of a chance to have them,
this book, to be universal.
I never intended
it to be universal.
I never intended for my emotions
that were very private to,
you know, link with that
of other people,
and it surprised me.
I was grateful that they
found that resonance.
>> Well, I'm sure we have a
lot of people in the audience
who have been inspired,
as I was, by your fiction
and by what it says
to us as a country.
But now you've written
this wonderful memoire.
You don't call it
a memoire, right?
>> Amy Tan: No, no.
It was a book about writing.
That's originally what I
thought it was, you know,
people tell you what
you've actually written
after you've written
it, including my editor,
who said it's a memoire,
it's, and I said no,
it's a book about writing.
But because it has so many
examples of my writing
from my real life, they ended
up calling it a memoire.
>> Your life has
actually, and your family,
and your background,
and your roots,
have really informed
every single thing
that you've written.
>> Amy Tan: I try to
get away from that.
[laughter] But when you're
writing about, you know,
the way, what has
shaped your writing,
it's not simply the stories,
the context of the stories.
It has to do with the way you
think, your whole cosmology
of the world, and
how things happen.
It's what is important to
you and morality and family
and consciousness and
also what you think
about between the
moment you were born
and the moment you died but
including the moment you died.
So these go into the
writing, and so I had to talk
about what feeds the writing.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
But you said something once,
or wrote something once
that is coming to mind
right now, which is,
you said I didn't write this
or write what I've written
to be remembered in the
minds of other people.
Some writers do.
You know, I want
to become immortal.
>> Amy Tan: I don't
write for prosperity.
>> I want to become immortal.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah, yeah.
>> You said I don't want to
be, that's not why I'm writing.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah, yeah.
>> Why are you writing?
>> Amy Tan: I want to
write in the moment.
I mean my whole purpose of
writing is almost to capture,
like a diary of myself
and what I was thinking
about at the time, and if I
have in my mind that I'm writing
for posterity, or, you
know, to be in the library,
somebody might look it up, you
know, a hundred years from now,
then I would get stuck.
I would write for
a different reason.
And so in my mind I always
have to tell myself this is
for the moment, and
if it ephemeral,
if it's gone next year or ten
years from now, that's fine.
And my motives then,
my intentions
for writing are very
clear to me.
>> This book, and it really
is to me, it seems a primmer
for writers because it really
goes into the way you think.
Not only the way you think
it goes into your brain.
You're talking about the
brain process, you're talking
about amygdala, which where
memory is supposedly held.
And you're talking about
your own sort of trepidations
about the way that
your brain works--
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> And, you know, where is it
coming from and do I have it,
and it's a very candid--
>> Amy Tan: You know, when
people say it's candid,
I think what did I
say that's so candid?
Or you're very brave,
and I think, oh,
maybe I shouldn't
have said that.
I wanted to know also because I
was brain damaged for a while.
I had Lyme disease that
went into my brain,
and it really made me foggy.
It made it hard to
remember anything,
and then I became curious
about how the brain--
I hope you can see I recovered.
I was [applause]-- so one of the
things that happened in thinking
about the brain and how
it works, I discovered
in taking this sort of
medication for seizures,
which this is what
Lyme left me with,
that this medication made me
too happy, which you think,
well what's wrong with that.
Well, if you're laughing
at what people are saying,
and it's not supposed
to be funny,
it can be rather distressing.
So, I found also this had to do
with neurologically something
going on, and I tied it then
to the idea that our brains
have these emotions in them,
they really are triggered
also viscerally,
and my stories have that too.
So one of things I did was
to take a visceral emotion
that I had about a vague
memory and then follow it.
As I moved forward with
it, then I would feel this,
I would feel nervous, I would
be aware that I was shaking
or that I would have something
going on in my stomach
that felt uncomfortable, and I
just kept following the story
to see where it went, and I feel
that I uncovered this
very traumatic memory.
Even if it did not
happen exactly the way
that I wrote it down,
it is in essence part
of my life during that time.
So that is part of my writing,
and you know, I say this,
it's not a primmer
for a lot of people.
This doesn't happen
to you where you go
into a PTSD moment, that's okay.
It is my, the thought process,
the brain, and emotional,
the emotional memory
process that I go
through in the writing.
>> You say that you started
this book by opening boxes
and looking at letters, and as
you were looking at the insides
of these boxes and what they
collected and the whole lifetime
of and other people's
lifetimes, that it was like,
and I love the expression,
you said it was like the force
of glaciers [inaudible].
You have this image of,
you know, oh my gosh,
you know, whole force going on.
>> Amy Tan: Things that
have been frozen in time
that suddenly were
revealed to me.
These were books of
memorabilia from my family.
I actually had 80 boxes,
and I took it down to seven,
and I had, you have to
realize, I was desperate
to finish this book, and I
was writing a chapter a day,
which is absolutely insane.
It usually takes me
years to write a book.
I was going to finish
it in about four months,
and it was an experiment
in part.
So I would take things out of
this, and it would be a letter
from my mother to me,
and it was a letter
when she was really upset
and hinting she was
going to kill herself.
And I took that, and
I wrote something.
And it might have been about
her language and something
about what she was saying
underlying these words.
Or I'd pick something up,
and I'd suddenly realize my
parents were illegal immigrants,
oh my!
You know. And that fed into some
of the things they said to me
that turned out to be lies.
>> Right, right.
>> Amy Tan: And one of them
was taking an old report card
out from an art teacher
that said about my art,
which I loved, I wanted to be an
artist, she has no imagination,
[laughter] which is essential
for a deeper creative level.
So I gave that dream up.
Thank god he didn't
say that about writing.
>> I want to point out that
she has one of her sketches
in the book, at least one--
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> Of a, of a, of a, of a--
>> Amy Tan: A bird.
>> Of a bird.
With every little feather in it.
It's a wonderful sketch.
>> Amy Tan: I draw
every day now.
I'm into nature journaling.
But part of was something
revealed to me in this book
which was that so much of my
life, my childhood was governed
by expectations and the idea
that something would
become public.
And I still am governed by
that slightly, you know,
the idea that maybe
if I write something,
some people are going
to read it.
But with the drawing, I do this
for myself, and I don't have
to show it to anybody, or I show
it, and it could be really bad,
and I don't care, you know,
because they did it
for pure pleasure.
No one is paying
for it, you know.
So that was another thing
I discovered in the book.
There was one, it was almost a
devastating discovery during the
writing of the book, and
it was about being told
that I was going to be a doctor
when I was six years old.
Somebody had tested me, and
then that was my parents,
and my parents said to me,
she said you're going
to be a doctor.
And then they say, and so
you can be a concert pianist
and a doctor.
[laughter] And then she said,
but she said you're not
very good with words.
Your English is not that
good, but that's okay,
you don't need a lot of
words for being a doctor and,
you know, playing the piano.
Well, this prediction
or mandate followed me
for the rest of my life.
I mean even to the moment
that I was writing this book
and I realized every time
I felt inadequate or dumb
or that I had never lived
up to this expectation--
>> I hope you still
don't feel a failure.
>> Amy Tan: It's not that
I'm a failure in comparison
to what other people might
perceive, but within my mind,
there is always something
there, and it has, there's no,
the problem is there's no
clear notion in my mind of what
that is supposed to be that I am
supposed to reach and say, yes,
I fulfill this potential.
So because it's so vague, you
know, I'm always not there,
and I did, I did sort of
erase it partially when I came
across this lie that I never
was supposed to be a doctor.
And it turned out the
test, this is a great thing
about the internet, you can
find out this test I took
in the first grade, and
the woman came every year
for two years, I mean twice
a year for five years,
and then she stopped, which
made me think that I flunked
and she wasn't going
to come anymore.
It was a different kind of test.
I found it on the internet by
googling 1958, first grade,
Oakland, IQ longitudinal, and
the first thing that came up,
it was a landmark
research on kids
who read early, and guess what?
Out of 5003 kids, there were
49 who could read early,
and I was one of them.
And my parents had lied--
>> And the school
didn't like that?
>> Amy Tan: Well, you weren't
supposed to teach kids to read.
There was a, you
know, a prohibition.
Parents are not supposed to
teach because you were going
to teach the wrong methods
and your child would be a
problem child from then on,
you know, a chronic
bed wetter or whatever.
And people followed
this to the hilt.
I mean kids today, they
read text messages.
You know, they're,
they're, is insane.
At age two they're, you
know, they're reading.
>> So were your parents
terrified
that they had an early
reader on their hands?
>> Amy Tan: No, they would
not say to the woman,
and she kept asking them,
how did she learn to read?
And they said, oh, you know,
her brother is brilliant.
Her brother is so smart,
and he didn't learn to read.
He started first grade.
He followed the rules, and
he was doing great later.
No, we don't-- and
finally it came
out that I had been copying
his textbook and I'd say
to my brother, what
does this mean,
and my brother was
teaching our cousins,
who didn't speak English, and
he had a little classroom.
You have to imagine, here's a
little six-year-old boy telling
our older cousins,
no, wrong, you know.
[laughter] And I was sitting
there in the classroom.
So I have learned to
read probably from that.
>> It's an amazing story,
and your parents were worried
because, you know, they thought,
because they were
illegal immigrants.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> This was going
to compromise them.
>> Amy Tan: That's what
I, that's what I realized.
You know, I always thought
my father was so honest
because he was a minister.
He was an electrical engineer
by, you know, to make his money
to support us, but he was by
devotion a Baptist minister,
and I thought, how
could he have lied.
And they lied about a number
of things, and I realized then
when I found the documentation
that they were illegal
and there were these letters
with the word deportation
that they were among many people
before and today who have to lie
in certain ways, not morality
ways, but in ways, having to do
with documents, so they
don't imperil themselves
and their families.
So lying and saying we
don't know how she learned
to read, you know.
We followed the rules.
We knew we should, they
said that like three times.
We knew what the rules were.
We didn't break them, you know.
And it was her brother
who taught her.
[laughter] Send him
back to China.
[laughter]
>> By the way, speaking
of going back to China,
I want to ask you this, as a,
you know, I was born in Peru,
and I came to this country
when I was 10 years old.
My mother was American.
My father was Peruvian, and
every time I went back to Peru
after that it was, well
you're not really Peruvian,
you know, you're an American.
You're not really, you know,
you're not one of us anymore.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> Do you have this experience?
>> Amy Tan: I grew up with that.
I grew up with a sense
of shame, both ways.
Shame that I was Chinese in a
school that was primarily white
and then shame, you know, when
I went among family friends
who were Chinese or in
a restaurant or any kind
of situation around
Chinese people
that I couldn't speak Chinese,
that I knew nothing about China,
and I had trepidations about
writing the Joy Luck Club
because people would
say you know nothing.
You got it all wrong.
Even my mother had said when we
first went to China that, I was,
this was how naïve I was.
They said, you know, when we
go, what if they think I'm one
of them and they won't
let me come back.
She just said, you know,
they just look at you
and the way you talk
and the way you walk
and they know you don't belong.
Later, she claimed, and
a lot of people claimed
that I was really so
Chinese, you know.
My Chinese did improve
because I have half sisters
who speak nothing but
Chinese, and it came back,
so I know that I spoke
it when I was a child.
It was in there, the
roots of that language.
And now when I speak Chinese
people say, oh, you're so good.
My Chinese is not that good,
but, you know, everybody thinks
that I'm just so
talented at being Chinese.
[ Laughter ]
>> Coincidence there.
This memoir, sorry--
this book about writing--
>> Amy Tan: It's okay,
it's shorter to say memoir.
>> Is actually, was
actually an unintended memoir
if I can say that, because
it's, tell us how it started.
It started with a
conversation through emails
with your editor, Dan Halburn.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah, yeah.
>> I would, my editor and
I are very good friends.
He is a dream editor.
He's one of those, if
you're not yet published,
you think you're going to have
an editor like this person
who loves everything that's
going on in your life,
loves your husband, loves, you
know, wants to know what you had
for dinner, and we would
write these emails,
and he so much enjoyed the
emails, and he was often saying,
how did you think of that?
Or I loved what-- and he
decided we should do a book
about our emails.
He said it would be easy.
You know, we'll just
choose a bunch of them,
put them in a book,
and that's it.
And I thought, great.
Well, I started looking through
them, and I said this is going
to be a book about egotism.
And it's going to be so
boring, and I told him,
I said, we can't do this.
And because I had already
signed this contract
and something had
gone out in the world
that said this book is coming,
I had to put a book together
about, and think of the book,
the emails were a lot about
writing and our relationship
as a writer and the kinds of
things I would talk about as,
you know, my insecurities
as a writer.
So, you know, this is going
to be a book about writing.
And in that book, there are
some very, very rough pages
where I just wrote them as I
was, they were part of the book.
I just wrote them down,
and I just put them in.
But there are some emails.
I told Dan, I said, okay, you
know, you suggested this book.
I'm going to put them in, and
we're going to include yours,
and you tell me which ones.
And then he freaked
out, and he said, okay.
I'm going to choose the email.
So in the book there
are a number of them
about our early relationship
as a writer and editor talking
about the book, and I think it's
good insight also into the kind
of difficulties that
a writer has.
That it's not perfect, and
if anything, people say,
well can you just
write this for me.
They don't realize it
is far more difficult
to write a little piece
as a writer than it is
for any other person because
you sweat over every word,
and you think it's horrible,
and you try doing
it again and again.
But the emails, they were
just off the top of my head
because they were just to Dan.
And so I put them in there.
You'll get to see how
insecure I am as a writer.
>> It's a very revealing book,
and I think in the process
of your talking about writing,
you tell us about your life
because you really
didn't become a writer
until you were in your 30s.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> You've been a linguist.
You've been an educator.
You've been a bartender.
>> Amy Tan: Pizza slinger.
Yeah.
>> Pizza slinger, car hop.
All of you out there
who have jobs like that,
you can also become Amy Tan,
because these are the things
that feed you in the
process of being who you are.
And the corporate, you were
writing corporate materials
and things like that,
that sort of thing.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> So how, tell us a little
bit about your decision
to actually site down and write
fiction and how that came to you
and how the impetus for
writing the Joy Luck Club
actually happened.
>> Amy Tan: There
was no single moment
that I said I'm going
to write fiction.
It's almost hard
to think, you know,
if there was a one day
revelation, but one of the times
when I was motivated was after
reading Louise Erdrich's book,
Love Medicine, which is about
a community of people in there
and different voices,
and I realized
that I had these stories,
but they were all
in different voices.
Now, they were primarily my
voice, but I had different ways
that I wanted to see my life,
through the voice of mother,
daughter, and different
situations.
There was another moment
when I started reading again,
and I was writing the corporate
business articles, and I was,
I was good at it,
and I have to admit,
I was good at writing the
corporate things about,
or employing motivation
materials, you know,
why you should work harder
for the same amount of money.
Very, very good at that,
and I had a lot of clients
as a freelancer,
but I was unhappy.
I would go down in my
office every day and I said,
will I be doing this
in in 10 years.
And I was making good money,
so it was hard to walk away,
and I said, I hate it,
I hate it, I hate it.
Then I would sit down
and I'd start working.
And I knew that I liked to
write, and so I thought,
well maybe I'll do this other
kind of writing, and I started,
and I wrote things that
were not very genuine.
I made myself a German
American girl, and, you know,
rich parents and all
that kind of stuff.
And it wasn't good.
It was not very authentic.
And then I gave up on the idea
that this would ever
be published.
I'd just do it for myself,
and I started writing things
that eventually would be
part of the Joy Luck Club,
and I went to writer's
workshops.
It wasn't a very good story.
I had a lot of problems
with it, but the questions
that were asked of me
that I had asked of myself
and what I discovered about
myself made me realize
that week I was going to write
fiction the rest of my life.
I was not going to
get published.
I wasn't delusional.
I said, I will keep at this,
so it's really important,
just the way that I'm
drawing every day.
This is important for me.
I don't have to have
it out there
in the world, but
it's important.
And so I started to
write with that notion.
I would, and to give me a goal
so that I wouldn't give up,
because I have this
dilatant tendency
to start something
and then drop it.
I said, I will work to
be published when I'm 70.
I have a little bit to go
still before I reach that goal.
When I'm 70, if I get
a short story published
in a good literary
magazine, I will be happy.
That's my goal.
>> You're a very
adventurous soul.
I know this because
in this book you talk
about going cave
diving, spelunking.
You go, you've had accidents
on the Italian autostrada.
You have had, you
know, hotel break-ins.
You've been mugged.
A million things
have happened to you.
>> Amy Tan: That's not
adventurous, that's bad luck.
[laughter] Or good,
because I'm alive.
>> Yeah, it's live subjects
to write about, but I think,
you know, for all that bad luck
and adventure that you've had,
the greatest adventure
I think is your family.
The story, the treasure
trove, if you were writing
about a German girl with,
you know, with rich parents,
I mean the real treasure
trove was in your family,
the stories in your family,
the extraordinary sort
of revelations that came
to you later in life
about your grandmother,
who was a concubine
and committed suicide
because she hated that life,
about your mother, who was,
it was an arranged marriage
that she hated, and then left
her children behind in China
to come to the United States
to be with your father--
>> Amy Tan: And kept
this a secret.
>> And kept it all a secret.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> And all of this was
emerging, I assume,
as you were in this process of
doing your corporate newsletters
and barhopping and
pizza deliveries,
all of this information
was coming.
Extraordinary stuff
to write about.
>> Amy Tan: Well, I
always thought, you know,
that my life contained nothing
that would ever go into a book,
that it was boring,
because to me a writer,
I'd read through one
thing, as an English major,
books only by male writers
except for Virginia Woolf,
that was the only one, and so I
believed that you would have had
to go through war, like Kurt
Vonnegut, or you would have had
to go through, you know, hunted
animals like Earnest Hemingway,
and I didn't have
any of that history.
Who would want to read
about a Chinese girl
and her crazy family and her
mother who just, you know,
has these horrible traumas
in her life she's trying
to get you to understand.
And that's why it was
so important for me
to realize I have to write
for my own reasons and not
to impress anybody else, and
once I got rid of that notion
of ever getting it published,
it enabled me to do it.
But, you know, I, to this day, I
keep thinking, I'm going to run
out of family material,
you know,
I can move on to something else.
And then I get another
revelation, you know.
It just, it just never ends.
You know, one of the
things that I thought
that my grandmother
was a very modest woman
and that she was quiet
and she was old fashioned,
that was what was told to me.
She was raped and then
became a concubine by force,
and then I found these
photos and a book that showed
that the exact costume she
was wearing was the one worn
by courtesans.
And I thought, oh my god.
I mean the one thing
you can say about that,
not that she was
necessarily a courtesan,
she was not old fashioned.
This would be like, you know,
your grandmother dressed
up as Britney Spears, and no,
she was not old fashioned.
And that was a thrill
to me because, you know,
I suddenly said, of
course she wasn't.
I mean look who came
out, my mother.
My mother, she's vain,
she wears nice clothes,
she's very consumed with,
you know, being respected.
And that also came from
her mother, who demanded
to be respected and
wasn't and killed herself.
I became my mother's daughter,
and I have attributes that come
from her, a certain
obsessiveness
where if I'm bothered
by something I cannot
stop talking about it.
But I'm unlike here
because I'm not suicidal.
I'm, you know, I
have my choices.
So it, you know, those
revelations where you find
out facts, you find out
about yourself as well.
I find, you know I find
myself in these revelations.
Now there's one big
revelation to me.
In doing the research for
this book, I found evidence
that my father and mother
knew each other in Chongqing
in a certain year when they
were sent to be in this place,
when the Japanese were
bombing their city.
They had met years
earlier, had fallen in love.
My mother had a baby,
and I was always told,
she was told she was
born in Shanghai.
She was born in Chungking
and Chongqing.
My mother and father were there,
and my sister did not know
who her father was, and it was
a possibility that her father,
my half-sister, that her
father was my father.
We were in the midst of
trying to find out how
to get tests done,
and the DNA tests,
you cannot see the father's
side, because as a female,
you are XX, not XY, and
trying to find a way
to discover what this was
and piecing together
facts, and then she died.
So she wanted to know.
She knew that was a possibility,
and she died, suddenly,
in March on a trip to Egypt.
I still have her DNA sample, and
if I could ever, ever find a way
to get some inkling of the
paternal side, I will do that.
>> More mysteries
ahead, in other words.
.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah,
more mysteries.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Your mother loved being
in your books, I think,
or having been mirrored in
your books, did she not?
She loved that aspect.
And a lot of people
say, whoa, you know,
what did your mother think,
thinking she would have
been appalled, disinherited,
not that she had any money, but,
you know disown me or something.
And in fact, she loved it.
At the very end of reading, and
my mother was not a big reader,
she said it was so easy to read,
and I knew that what she
meant later is she saw
that I understood things about
her that she no longer had
to explain, what upset
her, what irritated her,
what made her furious,
that that was in the book
and that I understand
that about her.
Oh, one of the funny things
I discovered in looking
through the memorabilia is
that my mother was
getting a graduate degree
in American literature.
That was on her student visa.
And the only American literature
she ever read was my book,
many, many years later.
[laughter] Yeah.
>> She was precious.
I mean she had some sort of--
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
She was going to make
American literature.
[laughter]
>> You were a teenager when
you lost your older brother,
the brilliant, Peter,
was his name.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah, Peter, yeah.
>> Who was a bit older than you,
I think a few years
older than you.
>> Amy Tan: A year
and a half, yeah.
>> And then six months after
that, your father died.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> Both died of brain tumors.
>> Amy Tan: Brain tumors.
>> And two quick
losses in succession,
which must have been an
extraordinary force of,
tragical force on your mother,
but on you as a teenaged
girl, how did that--
>> Amy Tan: The deaths
of my father
and my brother affected
me, I would say,
the most because of the way
my mother reacted to that.
>> Right.
>> Amy Tan: She went
a little insane,
and she believed we
were all going to die,
and she became even
more suicidal.
And at one time there
was a thought of all
of us going to heaven together.
But I was a daddy's girl.
I adored my big brother,
and I don't think I'm just
remembering him in a way
that comes from grief,
transformed over time.
He and I did things.
He showed me things.
Like he taught me how to read.
He played with me.
We read books together
later in high school
and talked about them.
And so I was profoundly
sad and isolated,
but it was my mother's reaction.
I'll tell you how insane
she was during that time,
and understandably so.
You lose our husband, your
connection to the adult world,
because you don't speak
English that well,
and you lose your son, who
it turns out I discovered
in reading the memorabilia
was her favorite,
and also was my father's
favorite.
Now this was devastating when
I thought I was the favorite.
You know, this made her a
little insane, and she ended
up taking us to Europe, and
on the basis of the fact
that Holland was clean.
She found a can of Dutch
cleanser under the sink,
and she decided that we'd go to
Holland because maybe my father
and brother died because
of some kind of germ,
and that's where we went.
We ended up in Switzerland,
you know,
and every time I tell people
I graduated from Switzerland,
they think I was, you know,
some rich girl, you know,
went to a finishing school,
but that wasn't the case.
>> That was a phenomenal
turn in events.
Do you speak French, then?
I mean were you in
a French school?
>> Amy Tan: Well, the
sad thing is that most
of the people there,
the students,
they could speak English fairly
well, so my French is very bad.
I speak better Spanish
than French by the way.
But I'm learning.
I'm an autodidact, and I read
Le Bon and I write letters
to people in French who
are friends who are French.
>> Which leaves me to ask
you, who were your models?
Who were your, when you were
thinking about actually sitting
down and writing this for
yourself, even if it took you
to age 70 to get it done,
who were your models?
Who were the people
who most inspired you?
Who were your, those
[inaudible].
>> Amy Tan: I would say
they were the writers
that I was reading at the time,
and that's why I always tell
people, if you really do want
to be a writer to just keep
reading and reading and reading.
Not to copy other
people, but to be inspired
by the fact they have
amazing, unique voices.
So Louise Erdrich, definitely.
She is one of our greatest,
greatest writers today,
and also Jamaica Kincaid.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Amy Tan: Who is a writer you
don't hear a lot about today,
but her book, Annie John, was,
I read that numerous times.
It had, seemed so simple
but it has this seething power
underneath it, every sentence.
And, you know, Isabel
Allende, who has these stories,
also these secrets, and
a family from the past,
ghosts from the past, and
people call it magical realism,
but you say, no, no, it's
what really happened.
And I love that part
of it, that, you know,
it didn't have to
be fantastical.
So there were many,
and I do have
to say they were mostly women.
But there were writers,
other writers that I,
and Maxine Hong Kingston
was another one.
Richard Ford, who I love.
And some of the writers
that I read in college,
but it had to do with
the writers I was reading
at the time and feeling
more and more this urge
that I was now older,
and I had to make sense
of the life I had
lived thus far.
>> All of this is in this book,
which is really a
wonderful book.
I couldn't recommend it more,
but I want to take you back
to a moment that you
talk about in this book,
and it's 2001, it's March.
You had just Bonesetter's
Daughter, and it was a book
that was inspired really by
your mother's gradual decline
into Alzheimer's as I
recall, and then complicated
by your editor's
bout with cancer.
So there was this,
trying to write this book
about your mirror on
your mother's experience,
your editor, and then falls into
this tragic state of affairs,
and you race to finish the book
for her sake, as I remember.
You go to New York to finish it.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah, yeah.
>> And then you, Lyme disease
comes into the picture somewhere
in there, and you're in
New York, strangely enough,
as fate would happen, when
the twin towers are struck,
and you watch from the street.
>> Amy Tan: I watched
the first one fall
from the CNN building on 37th.
I was the trivia
answer to which segment,
who was the person
being interviewed
who was cancelled
as a result of 9/11.
They said one minute to live,
then it was 30 seconds to live,
and I was sitting on the stool,
and suddenly the room
just broke into chaos.
And people were cursing at
each other, and I thought,
how strange, you know, that they
would not temper themselves even
if they were irritated.
And then I saw on all of the
monitors an image of a building
on fire, and having done many
interviews over the years,
I knew whenever there was
hard news, like O.J. Simpson,
you know, a glove was found,
that I would be cancelled.
So I just knew that a building
on fire, I was cancelled,
and I was going to
take this off.
And then I see there's
nothing behind a building,
it's just sky.
And then I heard somebody
say it's a commercial jet.
We have a witness, and
I realized what it was
and what was happening
around me.
We saw together in that newsroom
with all those newscasters
the second tower being hit,
and somebody saying, it's war.
And I watched the
second tower fall
as I was walking
back to our house.
We had a loft.
My husband was there, and
I just had to get home.
I was walking on the street,
and I saw it come down,
and I said, I'm dreaming this.
This can't be real.
And I don't even
remember hearing it.
It was so surreal, I just
watched this come down.
And we live 10 blocks from
the World Trade Center.
All these people were
running up our street covered
with this cement dust, many
of them looking shell shocked.
And there was such an amazing
camaraderie, a coming together
of the whole city
during that time.
But of course, this was one
of those moments you
say, I'm going to die.
What is my life about,
what is important.
>> Amazing sort of
confluence of events.
I'm going to ask one more
question, but I want you
to think about questions
that you will ask
because I will open
it up to all of you.
There are microphones
in the aisles,
and please ask a
question of Amy Tan.
My last question to you
in interview is what can
we expect from you next?
What are you working on?
>> Amy Tan: Oh, expectations.
[laughter] It's the question,
you know, my editor asks me.
Actually, he's fine.
We're having dinner,
and he knows never
to ask me that question.
It's a novel, and the title
of it is the Memory of Desire.
>> The Memory of Desire?
>> Of desire.
Now it's going to be
either one of two novels.
It's once that I dreamt
of about three years ago.
The entirety of this book
I dreamt on New Year's Day,
like a gift, and I read
over, I wrote down the notes
about what I had dreamed,
and a lot of times you dream
these things and they turn
out to be nonsense, but
it made complete sense.
It even had the subplots, all
the characters and locations.
The other was a book I
started about ten years ago,
and I found this
draft in that pile
of memorabilia, and I loved it.
And I thought, why
did I abandon this.
And when I read that again,
I thought maybe I'll do this.
And I had sent it to
Dan also a while ago,
and he could not let go.
He kept writing about a month
back and forth about this
but not wanting me to write
about wanting me to write
about this novel we
had talked about.
So, I don't know, it's
going to be that or that,
and I don't know if the
title will be the Memory
of Desire, but there you go.
It'll be a surprise,
just like everything
in my life is a surprise.
>> Well, I can't
wait to read it.
Do we have any questions,
people who would like to come up
and ask something of Amy?
Come on up, don't be shy.
This is a good chance to
connect with an author.
I have to tell you that there's
not very much in this world
that lasts forever, but when
you come up and ask a question,
it gets archived in the
Library of Congress.
[ Laughter ]
>> Amy Tan: Your sound bite.
>> So make it good.
You can say you're an
audio file forever.
>> Amy Tan: Your great
grandchildren will see it
in the Library of Congress.
>> Please, no pressure.
>> Amy Tan: No pressure.
>> So thank you so much
for all of your books
and for being here today.
Sorry, I can see you up there.
>> Amy Tan: Yeah.
>> I was just struck by the
beginning of your conversation
when you said that one of the
things that surprised you most
when you wrote the Joy Luck
Club was how universal it was
in terms of people telling
you it reminded them
of their own experience.
I'm just thinking of
the moment we're in now.
Crazy Rich Asians has
broken all records in terms
of box office receipts.
Is that also part of what is
important to you to see as sort
of broadening of the
popular culture acceptance
of all things Asian or is the
more humanistic approach more
important for you?
>> You know, in terms of
film, I loved that film,
and I loved it for two reasons.
I thought it was a fun film,
but the fact that it was
so successful, breaking
box office,
number one at the box
office, I felt this is going
to give Asian Americans a
chance to act in movies,
and they don't have to
be Asian American movies.
They can be anything.
The stories can be anything.
I don't think that
story is universal
because it does not represent
every Chinese person.
We're not crazy rich all of us.
Just as Pretty Woman does not
represent all pretty women.
But there is an expectation
people have had in the past,
and I hope that they'll get away
from that looking at this movie.
It's just a fun,
romantic comedy,
and a satire on rich people.
>> Thank you.
Next question.
>> Yeah, I heard you say, I
can't see you, I heard you say
at one point that
you're a linguist,
and how do you approach
dialect and creating voices
in different, with accents, what
have you thought about that,
and you do really well.
So I want to learn from you.
>> Thank you.
>> Amy Tan: I do love language.
That's why I became a linguist.
What I hear though mostly has,
that's more important to me,
has to do with imagery, and that
does reflect in the way I look
at my mother's speech, which
includes a different way
of expressing it in Chinese.
It's a context that has
historical, her history,
personal history, and a lot
of emotion over the years.
I looked at the changes
in my mother's language
from the time she was a little
girl speaking Shanghainese
and Mandarin and English
and then back to Chinese
and Shanghainese when
she had Alzheimer's.
What I, I don't have
to work at what her,
these accents or the dialect is.
It's simply what I heard.
And so I, I'm sorry
I can't help you
and say this is how you
do it, but if you were
to have a character who had
a different way of speaking
from the mainstream, I
think it would be to go
and have conversations
with that person.
Not simply overhearing
what they're saying,
but really getting into
an emotional conversation
about some ongoing topic and
how they express themselves.
Not simply phonological features
of that but how it comes out.
>> Thank you, next.
>> Amy Tan: Hi.
>> My name is Meiyung.
Thanks for your presentation.
Yeah. My name is Meiyung.
You had a good [inaudible] in
Chinese to write a good book.
But I'm thinking that if a
person who writes another book,
a different kind of book, and so
far [inaudible] is always talk
about fake news and some people,
maybe their driver
license will be denied
if they would try
to choose some work.
If somebody is writing this type
of book and will be restricted
from publishing or
get a copywrite,
do you have any suggestion,
that you can write another book
or something [inaudible].
>> Amy Tan: Thank
you, thank you.
Whether or not you write
a book and it's original
or whether it's fake or
whether you have copyright,
if you write what is true
to yourself and the way
that you think, not just
the story context itself,
that's always going
to be original.
And if somebody,
I've had people say,
well your character
is not depictions
of real Chinese people.
They're fake.
That is there perspective,
their reality, that they wanted
to see characters in a
certain way, just as they said,
you know, Pretty Woman is not
about every single pretty woman.
We as writers, and I assume
you would like to write a book
or you have written a
book, that it is authentic
to you and to your emotion.
>> Thank you.
Over here, please.
>> Hi. I'm delighted
to be here to say this.
I'm a high school teacher
in a public school.
I teach reading and English
to students with disability,
and we're about to start
your book, The Joy Luck Club.
I never taught it before, and
I'm excited, but I just thought,
is there anything I
could take back to them
that you might say to them?
These are 10th graders mostly.
>> Amy Tan: First of all, I
don't think that everybody
in the world, every student is
going to like a book equally,
and I think they have to know
that that is fine,
absolutely fine.
There's a way you might
look at a book differently,
not for the story necessarily,
not for the characters,
but perhaps asking if
there's one image in the book,
one scene that really struck you
as interesting, and just to go
into what that scene is about
and why it appealed to you.
The other is that we often read
books because they do resonate
with our lives, and to ask
a student if they would
like to share, now these
are very personal questions,
but if they would like to share
something about their own family
that feels similar and
the kind of pressures
or expectations their
parents have had
that seems similar like this.
And did they feel
they were understood,
because when I was
reading as a kid,
what I loved were those
stories that made me feel
that I had a friend, somebody
who finally understood me.
Yes. I understand that.
>> Thank you.
Next question.
>> Yes, thank you very
much for being here.
You mentioned after
9/11 when you were going
through the streets that it
was the kind of experience
that brings home to you
what is meaningful in life
and what is important.
What was that for you?
What were those revelations
to you on that day afterwards?
>> Amy Tan: It had to do with
family, and I was very glad
that I had lived a life that
was focused in that direction.
When I started writing, I asked
myself that question again.
What is the most important
I should keep in my mind.
And that, I reflected
back on my life
and said the things I wanted
to do, meaning how I thought
about things, how I treated
people, I was content with,
that I hadn't done anything I
should be feeling shameful of.
So what you should think
about seems to come
at the very moment
you think you're going
to die, and I was prepared.
I said, it's okay.
Now I'm going home.
I just want to reach
Lou and be together,
and if it happens
together, that's fine.
Thank you.
>> Thank you for the question.
Another question please.
We have time for two more.
>> Okay. You mentioned
that you have
at times had trouble completing
things that you started
and that you had to let go,
if I understand correctly,
of the fact that you
wanted it published
in order to complete that.
Is that what you were saying
earlier, because I'm trying
to figure out how you managed to
go from starting to completion.
Because I've started a million,
and I can never complete.
>> Amy Tan: Oh, that.
No, what I meant was I would
start different hobbies
and then I would let them go,
but that's true about
books as well.
I wanted to keep writing and not
simply get disinterested and go
on to jewelry making,
for example.
But I let go of books that
ceased to intrigue me or ceased
to be something that I feel
and become more mechanical,
where I'm interested only in
how to get to the next chapter
without feeling how
the story is going.
Now what happens is you
put it aside enough times,
you'll pick it up much later
and you see the direction
is clear now
or the character is
clear, and you're going
to change it, but
it makes sense.
So what I would say is
put those things aside.
Don't spend months
and months agonizing.
Move on. Or simply write
as fast as you can.
Don't think about the
sentences or where it's going.
Just do stream of consciousness
and see if anything comes
out after that that works.
Now I say all this and I
don't do it and I wish I,
and that's why it takes me,
and I know I should do that,
and it's in the book,
because I did it in the book,
and it worked in the book.
It just, I have to apply
it now in this next novel.
We'll see.
You'll get yours done.
I'll get mine done.
>> Thank you.
>> One last question please.
>> First I want to say it's an
honor and thank you so much.
This has been very interesting,
and I really appreciate it.
I also appreciate the
fact that you a linguist.
I am an interpreter and
translator, so it's awesome
to see a colleague up there,
or you were a colleague.
My question is this.
When you have a story to tell,
and it's integral to your story,
you speak about certain
subjects that you feel
like you can't leave
out of your story,
but you want to protect people.
How would you deal with that
or how have you dealt with it?
Because the intention is you
don't ever want to hurt people.
You make your peace.
You feel good now and
everything else, but you feel
like it's part of that story,
and you want to tell it.
>> Amy Tan: There have been
very few stories where I've had
that concern, and mostly,
you know, it would have been
about my mother, but she
gave me full permission.
She wanted me to write more
about her as a matter of fact.
She wanted me to devote
whole book about her,
which is the Kitchen God's Wife.
In this last book, I did have
some moments about family.
You know, over time
you have these moments
where family have betrayed you
or disappointed you
in a certain way.
And I learned something about
betrayal and forgiveness.
And it's not what you think.
What I decided is that
forgiveness has a lot
to do whether you want to
continue with the relationship.
And so I had to decide because
of the nature of the rest
of the story that I
had to include that.
Well what I did was I just,
I didn't include the name,
and I just changed the
relationship to a different one,
and I put down the good things
that person said as well.
So it wasn't just this person
was completely vile and vicious
and mean as she really was.
[laughter] And, you know, you
just, you find a way to do it,
never with hate or disgust.
There was one story, one
chapter I did leave out,
and I really struggled
over, and it was a story
about being molested
by a minister.
And it was a life-changing
experience, and it was a letter
that I would have written to
him and what it did to me,
coming out of that room
and how I was changed.
And I decided not to include it
because it changed the
nature of the book so much.
It was just like, oh my
god, where is this going.
And there was also a church to
consider that it might damage,
and I didn't think that this
person, who is long gone
from the church now should
affect the church now,
but I did write that letter to
the church to say when you talk
about your legacy and all the
people you've helped and saved,
you have to claim this as your
legacy as well, and you have
to make amends for it.
So I say it now, and I'm glad I
have the opportunity to say it,
but I did not include
it in the book,
and those are the reasons I
considered what damage would
it do.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Pretty wonderful advice.
Ladies and gentlemen, we've
talked a lot about bad luck,
but we've been very lucky to
have Amy Tan with us today.
[applause]
>> Amy Tan: Thank you,
thank you very much.
Thank you.
[applause]
>> Thank you.
Thanks everybody.
[applause]
>> Thank you, thank
you very much.
Thank you.
[applause]
>> You got a standing
O, oh my gosh.
[ Applause ]